reddit is the latest social media
platform to crack down on hate speech it
been a controversial forum called the
Donald
created for supporters of President
Trump a that more than seven hundred and
ninety thousand users and was kind of a
foundation for Trump supporters reddit
said the forum had broken its rules by
allowing people to target and harass
others with hate speech the Trump
campaigns communications director says
people who want to hear directly from
the president should download the
campaign app as you know where there's
been kind of a reckoning for social
media here and one of the one of the
founders of Reddit Steve Huffman said I
admit we have fallen short so they came
up with new rules that explicitly
straight groups and your users that
incite violence or the promote hate
based on identity or a vulnerability are
prohibited they said that they tried to
reason with this group that the Donald
for a while they actually quarantined
the group at first and but they said
we've given them many opportunities be
successful the message is clear they
have no intention of working with us so
they took this step yeah it's an
interesting sign of a trend here these
platforms used to be free-for-alls no
rules at all and now they're saying well
actually there are gonna be parameters
so it is a traveling part because
goodness public and companies are
demanding them yeah